when we spoke it in your comic-con I
asked you I said you've been a part of
like every major franchise how do we get
you in Star Wars and you were talking
about how fans have been pushing for you
to play soca and you said if it happens
it's because of the fans and now here we
are well then we have nothing confirmed
right now so and when that happens I'll
be very excited but okay okay well I
mean if it does happen like would you
credit all of these fans
so there's a million one percent beat
because of the fans yeah million in one
percent damn cat fan casting Litoral
Litoral fan cast that would be that
would be the day I'd be able to look up
the exact moment and the exact tweet and
the exact christening of this entire you
know dream experience if it were to be
confirmed but wait meteors I've got my
legs crossed got my eyes crossed got my
fingers crossed I'm gonna cross my like
tattoo finger here yeah I'm hoping to be
moderating a panel with you on it and
those cast those cast members you're
talking about you and Corey and how he's
a bit of a nerd so to get a Star Wars
role would he just flip the hell out
oh he would flip out he just could just
delights in it and he was able to visit
on briar patch when we were doing
Iranian sea which was a really um and
great episode so he's just you know he's
marathoned all of jane the virgin he's
seen every episode just because he
wanted to see the last two seasons with
me so it's been it's been pretty sweet
he's been very encouraging and very
supportive and I can tell you between
Star Wars and Star Trek his like four in
total Trekkies like we would yeah I
think I could retire I think if I got
those roles and those two arenas and I
just see like I'm good like what else
could there possibly eat a want or need
you know have you been quarantine with
Corey are you guys together you guys see
so many thousands of miles apart it's so
challenging yeah I'm here I'm taking
care of my parents my dad is six foot
one and
still in the 120s weight-wise they he's
four months cancer-free pancreatic
cancer so it's been a long journey for
this past year and going on a year and a
half now and I'm we're just really we're
just in our gratitude you know if we
were in that moment where he was going
back and forth through his chemo in the
middle of this quarantine that would be
really scary but luckily you know it's
just about being here and trying to feed
another six meals a day and get him to
gain some weight and so I've been just
sort of on that sort of nursing duty and
often I'm mostly for this past year and
a half so now that South was sort of the
dedication during this quarantine to
take care of him while he was still in
DC working on the stimulus package and
then we're in April and we were supposed
to have our longest vacation ever
you know just time period together
because he's been you know campaigning
the whole year I mean it'd be just and
it was just only a couple months into
our dating so we've not really had a
really good chunk of time together
because of our work and our family and
all of the other things so it ended up
being what was supposed to be our
longest time together now our longest
period apart from each other so that's
definitely been really challenging but
we've been you know watching briar patch
and kind of catching up with each other
on it and different shows and trying to
catch him on on the press that he's
doing and spread the information that he
has for folks to get access to funds and
benefits from the stimulus package and
continuing to push for the census and
other things together but otherwise it's
we're reading to each other we're trying
to cook together you know what a lot of
people are doing it's kind of estranged
from each other right now yeah I mean a
lot of couples are in this situation
like I was you know long-distance with
my boyfriend for two years we finally
live together but my favorite thing to
do is we would start a movie at the same
time and watch it on FaceTime have you
been doing you find us very creative
things we've been talking about like
yeah we're picking the next show after
briar patches done you got that you got
the dream that's my next step is the
long distance things and finally being
able to be together
yeah they're like you have a time line
or is it just like well it was supposed
to be this summer but you know I think
it's with everything now with the
quarantine I think and just trying you
know who knows how long this is gonna
last and so we just got to make really
careful decisions about moving and
because I just might both of my parents
are high-risk so I just want to do
anything and everything we can in this
next year year and a half whatever
period it is just being a state as
possible so I don't know if like a whole
move is the right move right at this
exact moment we'll see you know it's
gonna be it's hard to think about when
we're gonna be flying again and doing
anything that was plans
you know like plans one of those you
know it's it's just take me every day of
time yeah I mean speaking of that like
how are you coping mentally with this
whole thing and do you have like a
mantra or message to folks out there
that are struggling because it could be
uncertainty just makes everybody so
anxious well I think the reality is you
know we've seen a lot of inequality and
we've seen a lot of institutionalized
prejudice and discrimination that that
has made this experience very palpably
different for for people and so you know
for me I'm sitting here grateful that I
can take care of my parents
and that I can protect them and make
sure you know and who knows because
anything can happen but you know that we
feel pretty secure and what's going on
but we've already lost family members
we've already lost friends and the work
that needs to get done in relation to
people having access to housing and
health care and education and being able
to clearly be the on Wi-Fi and be
connected and have all of those
different types of services is just
really really critical and we're in the
middle of a census year so you know
people need to hopefully in this interim
fill out their census forms to make sure
in the next ten years that different
communities are counted and that they
have the resources that they need but
that's just one small thing that all of
us can be doing right now to ensure that
our neighbor is not
to ourselves are in a better place so
I've just been working with different
organizations and doing everything from
fundraising to just advocacy and just
highlighting the different communities
that are that are really suffering right
now you know we went from you know
saying some people would would be
completely you know sort of immortal in
the face of it you know we're like young
people are far lighter people of color
are fine or whatever and they're all
these weird kind of ideas that we're
going on online and we're seeing the
exact the reality pushed back on that
that there's a lot more people at risk
than we originally were communicated
about but they've been crying out for a
really long time and so hopefully in
this middle of an election year and and
with the things that are coming up for
and we do talk about student debt and we
do talk about a green new deal and we do
talk about you know what people like
yang we're talking about in the new
future like we're gonna see even that
much more layoffs because people are
gonna go it's gonna go more and more and
more digital in AI so I think there's a
lot of vulnerable communities out there
that didn't realize they were vulnerable
a lot of vulnerable communities out
there that have been crying out for help
and need and I'm just really hoping that
this time where people feel the
privilege of being board that they can
also channel some of that and so the
work that needs to get done to elevate
everybody so that we don't ever have to
see this kind of nightmare experiences
to be our friends again you know I've
been watching and really moved by quite
a lot of people stepping up and doing
what they can and just even just in
checking in with people and seeing folks
who are going yeah it's tough whether
they're alone in their house or not you
know or if they have a home that there's
still just so much love and empathy and
connection that is at the center of so
much of these conversations and so I
mean I just even the fact look at the
world that we exist now or you're asking
me about what my mental health is that
just never happened before and the fact
that that's the Overton Window is
shifted in that way that we're
communicating about it hopefully then
that means that we can do that much more
to integrated into our society in our
culture and a meaningful way so that
more people have access to to better
mental health and
the activities and reality is that that
are necessary to make that happen
you